what's the what's the most bizarre
michael jackson anecdote that you have
from being a publicist for him the most
bizarre michael jackson anecdote is that
michael jackson is the most
astonishingly was the most astonishing
and still her for me to get used to the
fact that he's gone was the most
astonishingly beyond human human being
i've ever met in my life the first two
rules of science are the truth at any
price including the price of your life
and look at things right under your
noses if you've never seen them before
and then proceed from there the second
law well the first law is the law of
courage the second law is the law of
astonishment amazement or
when you stood next to michael and
michael opened let's say the the first
page of a portfolio by an artist you saw
equality of awe in michael you had never
ever expected to see in your life it hit
you like thunder and lightning he was
the second law of science incarnate just
flat out astonishing
all right not exactly what i was maybe
looking for there but i i think wasn't
crazy it was very sane